censorship is a big deal and uh very
obviously
it's kind of crazy that last night what
you know you know what
what i think is i'm just gonna say this
let me slow down
alex jones is such a high target because
everybody for some reason
wanna they wanna know what he thinks
about stuff and when i say for some
reason i'm not saying i'm confused but
i'm saying it's like for the things he's
done for the things he said
for the for the show he's built over
these you know almost three decades now
he gets all of the scrutiny in the world
for being as high profile as he is
so there's there's tons of people who
get banned for no reason people who are
not high profile
but there are a lot of mid-sized people
especially people on the left who don't
get banned at all and say
crazy things so i'd be willing to bet
if i brought in a leftist
who said similar things to alex jones
nobody would care absolutely
but you know what unit probably was it
probably wasn't just about what he said
it was about we probably had a bunch of
activists sitting there waiting and and
pressing flag and report and whatever
and
and now the video's gone it's gone but
it is on bit shoot
so if you guys know what bit shoot is if
you go to the tim cast irl channel and
[ __ ] it still exists
because we have contingencies upon
contingencies it's just we'll see if we
can get it back on youtube not that i
think it matters i think everyone will
just watch it on bit shoot
i got to say too that show is so
freaking fun it was so fun
i got to watch it halfway through like i
don't even say anything man i just just
enjoy
watch you guys go to town it was i
michael and
alex oh my god geniuses like max
seriously super fun wow there it is
how about uh well so so that's it i
wanted to address that because
you know i think it was a few hours ago
we got the notification yeah it was not
it was like you have violated the
community guidelines this is a warning
and so the issue is i've had a bunch of
people be like yo take out these
portions put them right back up and i'm
like
if if we don't know exactly where
they're they're coming at us for this
podcast and we and
i have a general idea if we get a hard
strike we can't do the show at all
for two weeks so it's like do we just
take
i'll take a two-week vacation or do we
say
okay i reached out to google i said let
me know
exactly what we need to do and what in
this because i was already told this is
this is
important news i was already told by
google
you are allowed to interview alex jones
and have him on your show and talk about
whatever
he's just not allowed to do his own show
so then i said
after they took it down tell me what in
this we we need to snip because
apparently it's like tiny passive
comments that weren't even part of the
larger conversation you just said
some some stupid things or whatever and
they're like aha we got you so now it's
gone i was thinking we should upload the
full show on to minds
because i know you'd said that tom
bitchu or it's already on [ __ ] but we
should just proliferate the thing you
had said like
they can bust you for doing something
off platform right violates the truth
behavior when it comes like sargon who
actually got busted for that
um the guy that interviewed him didn't
get busted so if alex did something off
platform it wouldn't affect that that's
that's the bs thing like
they they they gave us they gave me a
warning
because of something he said but they
told me i could interview him
now i'm responsible for what a person
being interviewed says
or it was a long-form conversation
discussion
what am i supposed to do just tell me i
can't interview people you know what i
mean
that's that's that's i i understand like
you know
if we were live and they were like yo he
said this thing
because when you're live you can take
something out i guess i wish they would
strike the clip like give you a little
time stamp and then
unlist the video and send you a message
and be like oh just snip 10 seconds
yeah that's what they do with copyright
like if you make a copyright
infringement on youtube
it'll tell you the specific portion of
the that would be helpful
yeah we have we had a three hour and
like 45 minute podcast and they're like
at this one point
you're gone whole thing's gone so i was
like is that it because i'll take that
out and put it right back up and they're
like we'll get back to you
and i'm like uh-huh because there may
have been some other things whatever i
don't know
but i knew i said it was gonna happen i
kept how many times i say in that show
we're getting banned
that's it we're banned now three plus
three plus yeah i'm like oh we are so
banned
so and i banned where are you going
sleep
you're going to sleep dirt no
like legit we got this you guys can't
see it but it's a massive seven foot
bean bag right just chilling oh it's so
nice
can i turn the camera and show you if
you want yeah let's try it
okay giant the giant bag just sitting
there okay and so what i'm saying is
i would just i just lay down in the bean
bag but you sleep
yeah can you yeah should we run over
there and lay on it
yeah oh yeah this is a nice big room
you want to jump on it yeah let's go
come on jump on there all right here we
go yeah buddy
here's caleb yeah buddy don't be shy now
nice
nice this was what ian's doing
this was part of the plan of what we're
going to do for election night but
it's not you know but we did add the new
the new desk and so ian can chill and
then uh
you know i love it yeah but but uh but
we do have some serious stuff to talk
about so hey
there you go there's censorship i'll
just i'll just add real quick because
we'll probably come back to censorship
stuff
twitter said they they labeled 300 000
posts
that's the craziest thing have you guys
seen this new meme that's coming out of
this the
the flagging they're doing it's like the
babylon beat did an article
and it's harry potter's twitter account
and he says he's back
voldemort is back and then under it says
this claim about voldemort has been
disputed
click here to see why hogwarts is very
safe and secure yes yes there's a bunch
of stuff i saw the paul revere one
yeah yeah yeah the british are coming
this is disputed yeah click here to see
whether
taxes are a good thing oh no i saw you
know what titanic one yeah iceberg
iceberg that one's the satanic is
totally safe icebergs are totally
there's a bunch of them it's great could
you imagine it's insane so
uh anyway that brings me to i guess the
bigger conversation but
for the most part we are we are having a
post
alex jones episode chill out session i
had a bunch of people hit me up and
they're like
you did a good job man i i could see the
look in your face
and i was like yeah it was like a like a
circus
ringmaster where all the animals got
free yeah
but i don't know okay because i don't
know but you actually talked to youtube
and said can i have this guest on even
though
every every big tech company hates the
sky i didn't say it like that okay when
i talk to him but i did reach out to
google and said
are there any considerations for me when
i interview like
for when i interview alex jones like
basically i was kind of like
i'm gonna interview this guy what's the
deal
and they said there's no issues at all
none whatsoever
alex jones can appear on anyone's
channel he just can't have a channel of
his own
and i was like fantastic all right good
because if they'd said something like
we're concerned that he might say
something like this
i could have been like yo make sure you
don't i'm not referring to news items
i'm referring to behavioral things like
calls to action of sorts which is
essentially what got us flagged
he had said something that he wanted to
happen and i don't want to repeat it
because then they'll come after this
show too
because they're on edge but he he said
he wanted to see something happen to
somebody
to put it mildly and they were like we
got you so so it was a little bit like
what steve bannon said
i don't know right exactly he got
totally banned for what he said about uh
fauci i think it was
yeah something about fauci's head did he
actually get banned i don't know
about his stream he got him up his
channel got permaban and
on twitter and and youtube he's gone oh
my gosh i think it was youtube too
yeah i didn't know he existed on
anywhere until
fouchy until just recently did you guys
hear what fauci just said
yes yes yes he said totally sad totally
insane the us has an independent
spirit yeah but it's time to do what
you're told
oh not okay that's it i'm doing the
opposite yep
it's america
yeah i don't think so yeah not about
that what do i get in return
absolutely nothing yeah survive in
regards to alex getting banned
just his person getting banned i don't
like it because i feel like if a
criminal posts
is a criminal and they're off social
media they decide to post something
legal
that's like a step towards redemption
right it should be
but it's not look at this oh what are we
looking at oh snap
dr fauci tells americans do what you
were told oh you don't tell americans
that
we have a constitution for a reason you
know what you know i love how hard the
constitution makes it for these despots
to gain power
wonderful document i tell you what yeah
anyway you were saying about alex jones
being banned
i i i've tried when i was at when i'm
working at mines
i tend towards like okay if we if we ban
an account because they violated the
terms of service i'm not going to
prevent the account owner from making a
new account
that doesn't violate a new account and
if the new account doesn't violate
that's good that's a good thing i think
that i think that's like a good standard
actually
because if you if you're someone like
you know alex jones and you have three
million or whatever subscribers
and you break the rules and they say
that's strike one you break the rules
against right two you
break the rules for a third time they
delete you you gotta start from scratch
and they say hey start over
congratulations your account violated
the rules you as a person
can keep going and then you know you'll
start up a brand new account you break
the rules again then they delete that
account
too and then they're getting rid of the
problem but they're letting people
you know that's what they used to do in
2008 for instance warren25
this is a great youtuber look him up see
if he can find any old stuff he would
rail against george bush and scream and
profane
and eventually he just went over the
edge they banned warren 25 account so he
made one 25 smash
and went crazy and they was yelling and
screaming and i think eventually they
banned that but they never
banned phillip from making accounts
right it's a weird new
you know if anything is banning probably
helped his
account right when he came up with the
new one there's that many more people
who were paying attention to him because
he got banned
usually it's it's you you lose a decent
amount of people
you know it's kind of like is that the
way we're going though
are we going like this weird dystopian
black mirror thing where you have
merits and you lose them and you and you
cease to exist and you can't
you can't do anything that's it's going
to be here's here's how i imagine the
future right
in like two years everyone's going to be
wearing this like
weird like it's going to be a green and
white kind of jumpsuit
you know that uh what kind of materials
that's going to be like a nice it's like
what mouse pads are made of a graphic
neoprene yeah exactly exactly but
they're going to have they're gonna have
anti-grav packs on their on their backs
and they're gonna have like
white helmets with like green visors and
they're gonna be floating around and
they're gonna have like telekinesis
and three years in two years and then
and then you
are gonna be banned from the network and
so you're gonna be a regular guy and
you're going to be wearing like a
a brown duster covered in holes in dirt
and you're going to be like looking up
at the people flying around and you're
going to be like
i used to be one of them and they're
going to be you know like eating awesome
food and
they're going to be like well it's a
private business you shouldn't have
gotten banned
you're gonna like try and go to the
store but the door is like 50 feet up
you know
i'm kidding obviously you know what they
could do but i'm thinking severely
dystopian but you could make clothing
out of graphene and then make it like
haptic feedback
clothing yeah so if they get out of line
you just shock
shock them to hell or like knock them
haptic squeeze
yeah yeah but no no i mean honestly
think about where we're going right now
in terms of all the censorship stuff
because you don't you don't
you don't own your iphone okay well you
own the physical device but you don't
own the software
no you can't modify it you can't do
anything to it so
you could get banned from ios and then
also in one day your phone is bricked
you wanna know what the crazy thing is
banks banks are people oh of course
of course you wanna know what the
scariest thing is though
people use facebook and google to log
into other services
yeah if you get banned from facebook and
you use it as your login you're banned
from
every single account and there's no way
in
so a lot of these companies don't have
customer services you can call
if it's like amazon or whatever you'll
find a way to get your account
access or something but if it's using
like a different web service that's
linked to facebook and use facebook as
your login
let's say you use a an accounting
service or whatever and you just like
log in with facebook now you lose access
to your accounting systems you gotta
like try and figure out how to get in
and they don't care are they are they
gonna figure out a way for these for
these people who
who lose account access to continue
living their lives are they just going
to say well screw you didn't you just
hear what i said
people are going to be flying around in
their neoprene is it neoprene
i thought that they this was a session
for them to draw ideas from tim poole
he's the master they're going to take
you're going to be standing there and
you're going to take a potato sack and
sniff
two arm holes on the sides in a neck
hole and you'll be wearing an old potato
sack
and they're going to be flying around
and laughing and giggling and you know
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you